operations canceled patients turned away
from hospitals but the water crike which
struck 80 hospital trusts and 595 GP
surgeries in 2017 was just a prelude of
what could be to come a larger
life-threatening attack on critical
national infrastructure is almost
inevitable according to CEO of the
national cybersecurity center who said I
remain in little doubt we all be tested
to the full as a center and as a nation
by a major incident at some point in the
years ahead in its second annual report
GCHQ x' defensive offshoot outlined the
scale of the cyber threat facing the UK
in the last 12 months
NCSC removed more than 130,000 phishing
services over 14,000 sites dedicated to
spoofing government services and in the
last two years it tackled 1167 incidents
more than 10 a week the majority of
which came it said from hostile nation
states when it comes to cyber the UK
faced a dual threat on one hand there is
a deluge of constant low-level attacks
fake emails and random traffic sent to
overload servers just like these ones on
the other hand there are acute attacks
by governments that could literally turn
off the lights just like that protecting
the UK from both those threats is going
to require major changes in our use of
digital tools it's really important for
consumers to be number one aware being
more skeptical about the emails they
receive you know email is still the
number one vehicle for an attacker to
get into your systems and so just having
that mindset of being skeptical it goes
very far and yes are looking at
passwords and all the sort of things
that authenticate you as a user and say
the I am really who I say I am the NCSE
has causes in schools charities and
projects with businesses and government
will it be enough the fear is we might
all get to find out run a man top Sky
News